we begin with this in Missouri the
capital city took a direct hit from a
powerful tornado overnight the monster
twister touched down in Jefferson City
just before midnight witnesses say that
it caused catastrophic damage there at
least nine injuries have been reported
and now Missouri is under a state of
emergency hit by at least 13 tornadoes
in just the last 24 hours three people
have died in what authorities are now
calling a quote mass casualty event
across the state
Justin Andrews of our st. Louis
affiliate KMOV is in hard-hit Jefferson
City Justin good morning good morning we
are on the south end of Jefferson City
Missouri check out the damage that we're
seeing this morning this is on the south
end of town that is a gas station there
the awning has been literally ripped to
shreds and the sonic restaurant has also
a lot of damage here first responders
have been going door-to-door all night
making sure everyone is accounted for
here in Jefferson City a violent tornado
tore through Jefferson City Missouri
overnight leaving behind battered homes
and businesses there are several reports
of people trapped in buildings that are
severely damaged or destroyed all our
resources are coming in we have Highway
Patrol we have members of agencies that
would normally not be associated with us
form but they're all coming into play
windows of these businesses were blown
to pieces and cars were overturned and
tossed into buildings this gas station
was leveled and dangerous live power
lines littered the streets a deadly
tornado that killed three people
barreled through Carl Junction about
seven miles outside of Joplin where
eight years ago one of the deadliest
tornadoes in US history killed 161
people these are the terrifying sounds
people heard as a tornado made its way
through Eugene Missouri south in Pryor
Oklahoma
some drivers nearly traveled into the
massive twister another tornado leveled
these homes in Adair Iowa yesterday a
woman was killed when it tore through
and destroyed her home an officials say
more tornadoes and flash
is expected here in the Jefferson City
area we know that the Missouri task
force once sent about 80 crews from
their team to Jefferson City to assess
this damage we also know some of those
crews were actually affected by this
tornado as well luckily there have been
no reported deaths all right that is
good news so far thank you Justin